CORI PEELE: Welcome
to Cloud on Air.
Live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name's Cori Peele, and
I'm a Customer Engineer.
We're joined by Sean Ma,
Product Manager at Trifacta.
And we're going to
talk about wrangling
your data with Cloud Dataprep.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on
standby to answer them.
So let's get started
with our CE Chat.
So Sean, one of the
things we want to do today
is to talk about a bit of an
overview of Cloud Dataprep.
And there's some really
interesting applications
and use cases.
And I know you have a
wonderful demo for us.
We're looking forward to that.
And then we'll talk about
some benefits and next steps.
SEAN MA: Right.
CORI PEELE: However, when
we're looking at Trifacta, when
people think about
data prep and Google,
can you talk a little bit
more about who is Trifacta?
SEAN MA: Sure.
CORI PEELE: Yeah.
SEAN MA: Trifacta is a company
that was started in 2012,
and our founders
were doing research
at Stanford in
Berkeley, and their goal
was to enable users for
dramatic productivity
and radical creativity
with their data.
CORI PEELE: Excellent.
SEAN MA: I've been with
Trifacta for the last four years
and specifically working
on the Cloud Dataprep
product for the last two years.
CORI PEELE: Oh, great.
And so since your company has
been around for over six years,
why do you guys decide to
build a product in this space,
collaborating with Google?
SEAN MA: Sure.
So data today, as you
know, there's a lot of it,
and it's messy and diverse.
And too often, the key pieces
of information that you need
are hidden inside
patterns of data
that are hard to get to because
you can't understand what you
have, and you don't
actually have an easy way
to process it and transform it.
So our goal is to make sure
that people who use data
as their livelihood,
they can fix the data
and make it available
to whatever they need.
And at Trifacta, we
were really focused
on answering those
questions for users
and making sure that they're
successful with their jobs.
CORI PEELE: Oh, that's great.
So it sounds like we're really
able to use this to help people
get insight into a lot of data
to solve problems of all types,
including besides commercial,
but public service,
social problems.
That's great.
SEAN MA: Yeah.
CORI PEELE: Yeah.
SEAN MA: So we're
going to start off
with an overview of the
Cloud Dataprep product.
Just kind of set the stage
for folks who are new to it.
Dataprep has been around
since September in beta mode.
It's been around for
a couple months now.
But just to start things going,
so you asked the question,
like, why did we start a company
that's focused on data prep?
CORI PEELE: Right.
SEAN MA: And a big reason why
is some of these statistics
that I'm showing here, right?
We are seeing majority of the
time data scientists view data
preparation as the least
enjoyable part of the work.
But it's absolutely
necessary to get it done.
On the flip side, it's not just
data scientists who see this,
but oftentimes
analysts also spend
a ton of the time
on data preparation.
And once again, it's
something that they
don't want to
necessarily work on,
because it's actually
taking away time
from answering
those key questions
to get their job done.
So when we talk to
organizations about,
hey, what are some of the
challenges with understanding
your data and turning
that data into insight,
there are two big
things that come up.
The first one is setting up and
managing an infrastructure that
allows you to host a large
amount of data of diverse types
and then process a
huge amount of it.
The second part is often
then after you have that,
not having the
tools and skill set
necessary to prepare
the data so you actually
can do the downstream analysis.
So the key thing here is through
the combination of Google Cloud
Platform and its
infrastructure with ability
to immediately handle
pretty much infinite scale
and then leveraging
a purpose-built tool
like Trifacta for
data preparation,
we want to get data into
the hands of more users
and let them be as
efficient as possible
in processing their data.
And that leads to data
preparation as a service.
That's what Cloud
Dataprep is, right?
It allows you to visually
explore data, clean it,
structure it, whether
structure or unstructured data
or combine and modify
structured data,
with the whole goal
of making sure there's
zero infrastructure, no
need to deploy and manage
an environment,
and of course, not
needing to know how to code.
CORI PEELE: Great.
SEAN MA: So what does this
fit inside the data lifecycle?
So as you can see here, this is
a typical lifecycle for anyone
who works with data.
You take raw data
upfront, and then you're
going through a kind
of a discovery mode,
understanding what's
inside your data,
structuring that, cleansing
it, followed by enriching it,
combining with
other data sources,
validating it to make sure
it meets what you need.
And this is a very
iterative loop.
This is something that you
might do multiple times
and go forth from there before
you decide that you've prepared
the data or what you need.
You automate that so
you can do it repeatedly
for downstream analytics or
some sort of machine learning
or modeling.
Now, the goal with Dataprep is
to make this process here as
efficient as possible and
reduce the time you spend on it.
So for example, instead of it
normally taking months or weeks
to go to solve this
problem and go through all
the different steps, we really
want to make it days and hours.
So that's one part
of the efficiency.
The other part is actually to
enable different types of users
to actually access the data.
So this is not just for data
scientists or data engineers,
but also analysts, people who
are actually using the end
results of these analytics.
We want them to
have access to tools
that can prepare data as well.
CORI PEELE: Great.
So can you talk a little bit
about the governance process,
because I think some
of us, when we're
dealing with these
types of problems,
we end up on these
steering committees,
and they have a
lot of activities,
a lot of rules in terms
of who needs to do what
in what part of the process.
And as you mentioned, typically
that is a really long process.
So here, it looks
like you have a tool,
and it's available for
users in various roles
within this lifecycle.
So maybe just talk a little
bit about governance process.
SEAN MA: So since this is a
single tool that we'll show you
in a moment, anyone will be
able to see the exact same set
of transformations.
So regardless of
what role you are,
let's say you're in
the governance role,
and I'm the analyst that's
doing the transformations,
we'll both able to see
the exact same logic
that I've been
using, and you'll be
able to review step-by-step
of how I got to that.
CORI PEELE: Excellent.
SEAN MA: And because
it's a single tool,
we won't be, like, passing
emails back and forth.
We'll just literally
be able to work off
of the same piece
of information.
CORI PEELE: That
sounds great, and I'm
sure auditors will love
that traceability as well.
SEAN MA: Right.
Yeah.
So let's move on to some
applications and use cases
that we've seen Dataprep for.
At a high level, some of the
top applications that we've
seen here are data onboarding.
This is a scenario where
we see analysts dealing
with third-party data,
typically data coming
from external vendors
or human-generated data,
where there's a lot of
information in that data,
but you need to
standardize it, and you
need to restructure
the data in order
to meet internal
standards so that it can
be fed into built-in pipelines.
You can fill it into
reports down the stream.
The next one is data science
and machine learning, right?
So data prep is not just
a challenge for analysts.
It's also for data
scientists, because what's
the point of training a
model on a particular feature
if the quality of
the data is poor?
That can lead to
very skewed results.
CORI PEELE: Yeah.
SEAN MA: So making sure that
you've got the right data,
you isolate the right features.
Feeding that into the
model is important.
The last one is actually the
most common one we've heard,
which is big data
analytics, right?
And the challenge of
big data analytics
is that now, as more
and more data is
available of different
formats, it's
not just about processing
traditional or relational data,
it's actually combining
that data with social media,
combining that data with
file data, clickstream data.
So you can get a
very holistic view
of what's going on
in your environment
and analyze data based on that.
CORI PEELE: Great.
Yeah.
So when you're
looking at this, you
have a lot of different options.
You support a lot of
different use cases.
And in particular, when
we're thinking about,
like you mentioned,
machine learning, so let's
talk a little bit about how
companies are leveraging
data prep for machine
learning models
and what you need to do
before you start your feature
engineering.
SEAN MA: Yeah.
So I can give you an example
of a health care company.
So they actually started
with actually analytics.
So their challenge was--
so this is a large
health care provider.
They have dozens of
hospitals, hundreds
of outpatient facilities
throughout the United States.
And their challenge
was understanding
the resources, both people,
medicines, machine's, resources
across all these locations,
understanding what's there
and how the inventory
was stocked across that.
So the first challenge was just
gathering all this information
from the various systems,
traditional systems, customer--
user-generated
information, gathering it
in a single location just to
get a good picture of what's
going on.
And they were able to
do that through big data
analytics using
big data analytics,
because they could
see holistically
all of the datasets combined
and blended together.
CORI PEELE: Great.
SEAN MA: But once they had that,
what was interesting about it,
was that same data was then
useful for actually feeding
into a machine learning model.
In this case, it was
a flu predictor model.
So what they could do
was they could actually
use the information from
where inventory was, where
it was being used up, to
help feed into a model
and predict where
there was most likely
going to be a flu
outbreak, because they
saw inventories dip.
They saw patterns coming in.
So that's actually a case where
big data analytics eventually
fed into a machine
learning use case.
And they were able to deploy
that and to the benefit of all.
CORI PEELE: That's great.
SEAN MA: OK.
So these are some
of the use cases.
of the applications.
Let's talk about some
of the tasks and users
that we've seen with data prep.
I mentioned this
before, but it's
a fairly wide range
of users that we've
seen with Cloud Dataprep,
from data scientists, pretty
much anyone who uses
data, whether they're
analysts or engineers.
And as you can see
here, there are
a set of tasks that
are common across them.
So those include formatting,
restructuring, getting data
into a format that you will
understand so you can do things
with it, then
profiling that data
to get a sense of the
shape of the data itself.
So you can understand
the characteristics,
how clean it is, what are some
of the potential anomalies
inside that data.
And then universally
what we've seen
is that no matter what,
the data is dirty and needs
to be cleansed.
So standardizing it, fixing
out the common issues.
So that's kind of
like the common tasks
that we've seen across all.
Then we've seen data
scientists, in particular,
but to some degree
data engineers,
focusing on pattern
identification and distribution
models as well as,
as I mentioned,
training ML models
for predictions
and usage down the load.
So that's kind of where we see a
lot of pattern, data scientists
and data engineers.
Now, what's interesting
is that after you've
got the data in the
format that you want,
everyone wants to do some
sort of ad hoc analysis.
Now, if you understand the data
better, you can explore better,
you can find new
insights inside of that.
And once you do, you typically
want to enrich the data,
combine it with
other data sources,
and with the end
goal for analysts,
in particular, to visualize it
in some sort of dashboarding UI
or BI capability.
CORI PEELE: So how does data
preparation differ from ETL?
Because some of
these common themes
around enrichment and
cleansing are often
a part of that type
of process as well.
SEAN MA: Yeah.
It's a great question, something
that we get quite often.
So it's not black and white.
In fact, oftentimes
these two concepts
are complementary to
each other, right?
Typically, ETL is focusing on
well-defined structured data
while data prep is handling
unstructured, complex data
that's coming in from
non-relational sources.
So that's one area.
But as part of
that, you also see
a difference in the style
in which the tools behave.
So data prep solutions
typically combine
visualization with
machine learning,
all put together into an
interactive user interface
so that you can
access multiple users,
while ETL is focusing on a
metadata-driven mapping that
connects kind of a
flow through the data.
So these two are complementary,
but they're really targeting
different types of users.
And then I'd say
one key difference
that you might choose is
that the time to insight.
In particular, if you're
dealing with ad hoc data or data
sources that are
changing quite a bit,
you may want to use
data prep, because it
has a little bit more
flexibility for these changes
and go forward from there.
CORI PEELE: Oh, great.
Well, I'd love to see
how this works in action.
SEAN MA: Yeah.
So I've got a quick
demo to go through.
So hopefully highlighting
some of the capabilities
of Dataprep.
Before I start, I'm actually
going to go ahead and just give
some context on
this demonstration
and then I'll jump into
the product itself.
So this demo, as
you can see here,
I've got actually two datasets
on the left-hand side here.
One is a clickstream file.
You can see it's kind of--
it's got URL information
and dates and click behavior.
I want to take this
clickstream data
and combine it with sales
order data from a website.
This web order data
is stored in BigQuery.
So I want to combine
that with a goal
of generating a nice
dashboard to understand
where things are being--
where consumers have been
purchasing from as well
as what is the most
often clicked items,
and do they lead to orders?
So things I want
to pull out of that
is a correlation between
clicks and orders.
I want to extract out products
that have been purchased
and get a sense of
the quantity for that.
And of course, during
this whole process,
I'll be cleansing the
data, preparing it
for this downstream
dashboarding view.
OK.
So let's switch off and actually
get into the product itself.
So just starting
from the beginning,
how am I to launch
Cloud Dataprep?
While in the Cloud Console,
you can go to the menu here.
You can go down to
the Big Data section,
and you'll see Dataprep.
So clicking on that,
that will launch Dataprep
from the console.
I'm going to quickly
full-screen this.
CORI PEELE: And I like
to have my big data
items pinned as well.
So those using the console
like to have it at the top.
SEAN MA: Definitely.
CORI PEELE: Playing
around with it.
SEAN MA: Definitely.
So once you enter
your Cloud Dataprep,
you'll see this
workspace where you're
kind of showing all
the flows, basically
organizations of analysis
that you're working on.
And for this particular
demonstration,
I'm going to create a new one.
So I'm creating a new flow.
I'm going into call it
Click To Order Analysis.
I'll go ahead and create that.
And I mentioned that my
datasets were in Google Cloud
Storage and BigQuery.
It's files and a table.
So I'm actually going
to import that live.
As you can see here,
inside Dataprep,
you can browse
through Cloud Storage.
So I'm actually
browsing the buckets
that are default in my project.
Inside of this, take a look
at some of the folders.
I see website clickstream data.
I see, OK, clickstream
across multiple years.
I look inside, just take
a quick look inside.
Is this the data
that I'm looking for?
Yeah.
This looks kind of like
the data I'm looking for.
So what I want to do is
I actually want to take--
for this demonstration,
I'll just
take fiscal year
2010 as my starting
point for my clickstream data.
So I've that here.
CORI PEELE: Oh, a whole folder.
SEAN MA: Yeah.
I've added that whole folder.
It's my clickstream data source.
And then I need to go
take a look at BigQuery.
So now again, I'm browsing
the BigQuery data sets
available inside my project.
I'm looking inside this
one, do a quick scan.
No.
This is not what
I'm looking for.
So let me go back.
Well, I bet it's under here.
OK.
So taking a look at this, I
see Customer Sales Master.
It's got half a
billion rows there.
And then I've got
Daily Customer Sales.
For this demonstration,
I'll probably
take the Daily Customer Sales,
just for a quick demonstration.
So Daily Customer.
So I'll just do Customer Sales.
OK.
So as you can see here,
I've got two datasets.
I do want to mention
that if I didn't have
my datasets in Google
Cloud Storage or BigQuery,
I can actually upload
data, whether it's
CSV, JSON, or Excel files.
So you can also upload
it and make it a dataset.
But let's go ahead with the
two datasets I have here.
So I go ahead and import that.
So now what you'll
see is representations
of those datasets
in Cloud Dataprep.
Just so we're clear, these
are read-only representations.
So I'm not actually
modifying those data.
And I'm going to start
with the clickstream data,
and I'm going to
start preparing it.
So in order to do that,
I'm going to go in,
and I want to take a look at
it within the Dataprep UI.
So if you recall, when we
first looked at the raw data,
it was kind of jumbled.
It was hard to understand.
What Dataprep does
are the boxes.
It actually scans the data,
tries to understand it best.
It will break it up into
easy-to-read rows and columns
where possible.
And as part of the
rows and columns,
it will do things like
identify the column names--
so this is probably
in the file itself--
as well as infer data type.
So in this case, it's inferring
that this is a date time.
If you keep going it thinks URL.
There are various data types
that Dataprep can infer.
So it will
automatically apply them
without you having
to do anything.
The next thing you
might notice at the top
is what's known
as a quality bar.
So that's this item up here.
It kind of gives
you how many items
inside this particular
column match
the data type that's up here.
And looking at event
time, I can see
while there is a lot
of matches up here,
I see actually quite a
bit of mismatched values.
And knowing data
quality is usually
a big problem for any
analytics, I actually
want to understand more.
So I'm going to go take a
look at the column details.
So I click Column
Details, and now I
can see a lot more
information about the data.
So this was Daytime Data.
I can see it
distributed over time.
I can see it broken up
into months and weekdays.
But the part that I'm interested
in is the mismatched values.
And looking at
this, I can clearly
see the most common mismatched
value is error timeout.
Well, this is not going to be
particularly useful for us.
So what I want to do is
I want to get rid of it.
And the way I do that
is actually interacting
with this histogram here.
So I'm actually going to
click on this histogram.
And what Dataprep will
do is it will actually,
based on that click, suggest
transformations that I
might want to apply to this.
In this case, it's suggesting
I might want to keep those.
That's not the case,
but my second suggestion
is actually to delete the rows.
So what's happening
under the covers?
Dataprep has a machine
learning model that's actually
understanding-- that's
actually looking at what you've
been clicking on and looking
at some past behavior
for an aggregate
across many users
and suggesting transformations.
In this case, I'm going
to delete this data here.
So let me go ahead and add that.
And you'll immediately notice
that my histograms have
been updated with the fact
that those rows of data
have been deleted.
So looking at this, I still
see mismatched values.
So there's still a problem.
I still see more issues here.
There seems to be something
wrong with the date,
but I don't quite understand it.
So I'm actually going to
take a look at the Patterns
view of this column and take a
look at what's inside of that.
Now, looking here, Dataprep
has scanned that column
and identified there
are three patterns
for this date/time field.
I see year year/month month/date
date, 24 hours, minutes,
and seconds.
The next one is year/month/date
but 12 hours, minutes, seconds.
And then I see these
ones here, which
are the month abbreviation,
which definitely
is going to cause an issue.
So knowing that I'm eventually
going to do analytics
with this, most
systems don't like
having different date formats.
What I'm going to
do is I'm actually
going to click on the
format that I want,
which is this one here.
And once again,
Dataprep will suggest
various transformations.
And the one I'm
most interested in
is actually converting the other
patterns into a standard one
here.
And Dataprep is
showing me a preview.
In the blue was what the
original data looks like.
In the yellow is actually
what it's suggesting
the transformation to.
So I can see that
November when will
be converted into a number and
12-hour time format changing
to 24-hour time format.
So that looks like what I got--
what I want.
So I'm going to go ahead and
apply that and go ahead and add
it.
Great.
So now I don't have
any more issues.
My data is all one pattern.
Let's go back and take a
look at the Grid view itself.
And again, this is all--
I just remind--
I'm not actually changing the
source data at this point.
All this is happening
within my browser.
So it's just happening
in this view here.
So this one looks--
the event time looks good.
I'm going to keep going.
Looking at these quick
histograms across,
I can see distribution of data.
I see something weird
going on with user ID.
Hmm.
I would expect this to be
a much better distribution.
There's clearly one user
ID that's sticking out.
It's actually happening out
many more times than others.
So I'm actually
going to select that,
and I'm actually going to view
which rows this is affecting.
So looking at a user
ID, I can see it's all
coming from the same URL.
Oh, that's weird.
The event time for
this, these clicks,
are all happening the same time.
OK.
This could be a
bot of some sort.
CORI PEELE: Hm-hmm.
SEAN MA: So you know what?
I don't think this is going to
be useful for our analytics.
So for this case,
I'm actually going
to go ahead and delete it.
So I'm going to choose to delete
those rows and add that in.
And immediately Dataprep will
show me the redistributed data.
So I'm just looking around.
And the URL looks
a bit more even.
OK.
The last part I know I need to
do was extract a product ID.
I was looking-- I was
interesting to see
when people click, what product
they were clicking through on.
Let's take a look at the URL.
Normally, a product
ID is part of that.
And lo and behold,
yep, you can see this.
At the end of the URL, you
see product ID and the number.
And you can see that for
different products going
forward.
So my next step is I want to
extract this information out
and use it for--
use it in my dashboard.
So how am I going to do that?
Well, with Dataprep,
you can just
click and highlight the data
that you're interested in.
And that same machine
learning model
that's providing
suggestions will actually
take that data
that I've selected
and suggest a pattern
that matches it.
So in this case, it's a pattern
and apply to all the rows.
And here you see a preview
of the data that's extracted.
This is looking pretty good.
I'm going to go
ahead and add that.
Then one last step,
I probably want
to know which website
this is coming from,
but I don't need to know all
this information-- the page
information.
So I'm actually going
to click on the URL,
and I'm going to take
a look at the ability
to extract a domain.
So I'm actually going to
choose to extract a domain.
Yep, it's pulling out the
domain information for this.
That looks like what
I'm looking for.
Cool.
So I'm going to add that
to my dataset as well.
So now I've pulled out two
key attributes, the domain
and product ID.
Overall, this is looking
like pretty good.
Great.
So I think my clickstream
data is at the state
that I'm looking for.
My next step is to combine
this with the customer order
data that's stored in
the BigQuery table.
So before I do that,
I actually want
to just take a moment to note
everything I've been doing
has been stored in
what's known as a recipe.
And these recipes contain
individual transformation steps
based on your user actions.
So as you can see here, every
single step that I've done
has shown up here.
And the nice part
is that if I ever
want to go back and kind of
understand what's going on
or how my transformation
was performed,
I can actually go
back and click and see
what the data looked like before
I applied that transformation.
I could also edit
a transformation.
So if I made a mistake, and
I want to edit something,
I can go ahead and do that.
I don't want to do
it in this case.
I can just replay.
This is really
helpful, in particular,
when you're doing
data governance
and other people want to
understand what's going on,
they can literally
step through one
by one on what
you're operating on.
CORI PEELE: Oh, yes.
Auditors will love this.
SEAN MA: Yeah.
All right.
So let's go ahead and combine
that previous dataset.
So I'm actually going
to add a new step.
I'm going to actually
join data in.
So I am going to look at what
datasets I pulled in earlier.
Customer sales was
what I was looking at.
Let me just preview
that just to make
sure this is what I wanted.
To get a quick look, yep,
sales order, key-- yeah--
and customer key.
OK.
This is looking
like what I want.
So let's go ahead and
choose the Join Keys.
So behind the scenes,
Dataprep is actually
analyzing the two datasets.
And it's actually
going to come back
with a recommendation on
how to best join the data.
And lo and behold,
it is suggesting
that I combine the data based
on user ID and customer ID.
Once again, do a quick scan.
This looks like it makes sense.
Great.
So these are the two
columns that I join on.
I actually want more
columns inside of this.
So I'm going to add all of them.
I'm going to remove the
customer key for this.
And I probably don't need
customer-- this information.
But this is probably what
I'm looking for here.
Yep.
So now I've selected
the columns.
Quick preview of what I want.
And now I'm going to add this
join to the recipe itself.
So this join, like
I said earlier,
was going to be
down in the browser.
And when I scan through
my new dataset view,
I can see not only my
original clickstream data,
but now I can see all
that joined-in data
with the sales order key, order
date, customer state, customers
zip code.
Cool.
So this is actually
looking pretty good.
I think I have all the
information that I need.
Let's see if there's any
other things I can pull out.
Oh.
I noticed something.
What is this sales order lines?
Hmm.
This is kind of interesting.
It looks a little bit--
oh.
It actually looks
kind of complicated.
Oh, yeah.
CORI PEELE: Oh, nested.
SEAN MA: Oh, it looks like
there's some nested data
inside my BigQuery table.
Great.
It looks like I'm going
to have to get that out.
That's not going to be fun.
Well, let's see.
Well, Dataprep has figured
out that this is an array.
So let me see, if I
click on the column,
let's see what it suggests.
Oh, OK.
It's actually suggesting
that it might flatten
the array into new rows.
So convert each of these
items into individual rows.
So let's see what
that looks like.
I'm just going to select that.
OK.
Now it's pulling out each item.
Yeah.
It's looking at each line
item in the sales order
and pulling down
into individual row.
OK.
It duplicated the rest
of the information.
That's good.
OK.
So this is looking good.
So I'm going to add this in.
So it's flattened that out.
And now, notice that the
histogram has also changed.
It's actually broken it
down into the elements
inside this object.
So this is a sales order object.
I can see the
individual elements
like product key,
ship date, quantity.
Well, the histogram
is actually updated
to show those same things.
So now if I want to pull
out just those pieces
of information, I can
click on Product Key
here in the histogram.
And it will extract that out.
I'm also interested in quantity.
So I'm actually going
to add quantity to this.
And go ahead and add it there.
Great.
So I'm going to add
that quickly to this.
OK.
I've got product
key and quantity.
All right.
One last step, and then going.
So now I've got the data in
the format that I wanted.
I want to run this against--
I want to run this and process
a full result. So what I'll do
is I'll go ahead and Run Job.
By default, Dataprep
will generate a CSV file,
but you can change
it at any point.
So I'm going to go
ahead and click on this.
And if I wanted to change
it to a JSON file, I can.
So I can generate that.
But in addition to
that, I actually
want to publish
this to BigQuery.
So I'm actually going to
go back into BigQuery.
I'm going to go to
this Demo environment,
and I'm going to
create a new table.
I want to call this
clickstream data,
but instead I actually
wanted to call it
Click To Order Analysis.
OK, great.
I'm going to save the settings.
So I've chosen to append
this table after every run.
So if I run this
again and again,
it'll just keep appending.
So I save that setting.
And then I'm going
to click Run Job.
So what's happening
under the covers
is that Dataprep is taking
that recipe, converting that
into a Dataflow job, and
now that Dataflow job will
be executed against
a source data
and generate a
new target result.
If you want to take a look
at what that looks like,
so I can go to More, and I can
view the Dataflow job itself,
just see where that's
being kicked off.
Yep.
Great.
So that's looking good.
OK.
So this is going to take
a little bit of time.
So through the
magic of demos, I'm
going to go to a
previously completed job.
So I have a couple jobs
that I've completed here.
I'm going to take a look at
what the result looks like,
click on View Results.
And there I get to see a
whole view, a detailed view,
a profile view of all
the data that was run,
how many rows you have generated
across all the columns.
OK.
This is looking good.
The last thing I want to
do for the demo is then--
what I want to do is take this
dataset and actually go back--
so go back to my Click
To Order Analysis.
And what I want to
do is then schedule
this for repeated runs.
I'm going to go ahead
and add a schedule
this on a weekly basis, Sunday--
Actually, I'm going to
do it Monday at 9:00 AM.
Great.
OK.
So that's about it.
I've got this scheduled.
I can go program
its destinations.
I'm done with my demo.
CORI PEELE: That's excellent.
And you did that in a matter
of minutes, whereas some of us
have had to deal with a lot
of meetings and SQL scripts
and Cron jobs and a lot of
other tools integrated just
to get to that result.
So this is a great demo,
really impressive.
SEAN MA: Thank you.
So quick recap.
So what did we just do?
We adjusted data from
various sources that
was prepared through
Dataprep, and then
Dataprep used Cloud Dataflow
to generate the refined data,
which was then
loaded to BigQuery,
and from there, you can use that
through Data Studio or Cloud
ML.
So I'm going to quickly recap
some of the key benefits
and capabilities we just saw.
You saw a lot of--
you saw the first one, which was
interactive data exploration.
As you see patterns in data,
you can literally click on them.
And clicking on
them will generate
predictive transformations.
Those transformations
will be based
on what you clicked
on, the type of data,
and the model underneath.
The model underneath will
suggest transformations
that might apply.
And then when you do
any of these actions,
you get immediate feedback
as to what they might do.
And then the key benefits
for this whole solution
is that it's all fully managed.
The entire solution
is self-service.
Anyone who has access
to your Cloud Console
can then access the
data and explore it.
And then they can generate a
repeatable data preparation
pattern.
OK.
Well, with that, I'm
going to kind of wrap up
with the next steps.
All I can say is that if
you want to try this out,
go to your Console, and you can
launch Cloud Dataprep today.
From there, you can
enjoy a tutorial
and start wrangling
your own data.
CORI PEELE: OK.
Great.
So you see the URL to go to
cloud.google.com/dataprep.
So stay tuned for a live Q&A.
We will be back in less than a
minute.
Thanks.
Welcome back.
So Sean, we have a few
questions from the audience.
And I may throw in a
few of my own as well.
So what's next with
Cloud Dataprep,
and are there some new
features you want to highlight?
SEAN MA: Of course.
So there's actually quite
a lot to talk about what's
coming next for Cloud Dataprep.
If you stay tuned, there will
be some announcements coming out
soon.
But we're focusing a lot
on providing new developer
productivity enhancements.
So allowing users to transform
the data more efficiently
with additional tools.
We're also focusing a lot
on team-based collaboration
and sharing.
So that's some things
that we'll be announcing
in fairly short order.
And of course, overall,
we'll be enhancing
some of the favorite
features people like to use.
In particular, reschedule
jobs, enhancing that.
And soon you'll see a new
revamp to the overall UI.
CORI PEELE: Oh, excellent.
And so how many customers
have adopted Dataprep so far,
and is this supported globally?
SEAN MA: So actually, yes,
Dataprep is supported globally.
In fact, as part
of this, we have
almost 1,000 different
organizations
signed up for Dataprep
around the world.
At this point, they're
literally running
thousands of jobs a day.
And we've seen a lot of interest
out of Asia, out of Europe.
I mean, pretty much
everywhere you can think of,
we've seen Dataprep users.
CORI PEELE: OK, great.
And so when you run a job, where
does the data processing take
place and those
Dataprep store data?
SEAN MA: Sure.
So as I mentioned when I
went through the demo, when
you click on Run
Job, what's happening
is that Dataprep is taking
that recipe, the steps that
are defined inside that
recipe, translating that
into a Dataflow job that
you saw on the screen that
went through the execution.
That Dataflow job reads source
data from your GCP project,
transforms that data
within your GCP project
and writes it back out
into the same project.
CORI PEELE: OK.
SEAN MA: So actually
the data always stays
within that project
and doesn't leave it.
And all the processing
is done there.
In terms of storage
of data, Dataprep
itself doesn't store any data,
because what you're actually
seeing-- what we're
doing is we're actually
asking Dataflow to
actually run the processing
and generate the new dataset.
CORI PEELE: Oh, excellent.
So that way, if I need to
keep all my data in Europe,
and I have my project
set up to be only
in Europe, same rules
for Cloud Storage,
then that's where it stays.
SEAN MA: Sure.
CORI PEELE: OK.
Great.
OK.
And I know some
people really like
to know more about
pricing when it
comes to some of these tools.
Do you want to talk a little
bit about the pricing model?
SEAN MA: Sure.
It's actually very
similar to Dataflow,
and it's based on the amount
of processing resources
that you take.
So there is a flat charge
based on the total hours
that you're running a job for.
CORI PEELE: OK.
And when we talked
about a couple
of use cases, so we described
how people can explore
data, how you have data prepared
for ML feature engineering,
preparing for
that, but also when
it comes to data
onboarding, there
are also some
other things people
need to do for those
types of use cases.
So can you talk a little bit
about how people are using
Dataprep for data onboarding?
SEAN MA: Yeah.
So data onboarding,
when you're dealing
with data that is slightly--
that is similar in
content but not quite
of the right structure, so
with Dataprep what you can do,
you can easily re-order
and re-structure
that data to match what
you expect at standards.
And then from there, as you
saw with the date/time example,
you can actually standardize
formats fairly easily.
If you think about
it, that was actually
standardizing date/time,
in particular, is hard.
So we made that fairly
easy through Dataprep.
CORI PEELE: Oh, that's great.
And the customer
dilemma, a lot of people
have a lot of meetings
defining what is a customer?
What are the attributes from
all these different sources,
CRM, ERP?
So it looks like in
terms of data onboarding
or if you're doing
M&A activities,
this is a really great tool to
do that type of exploration.
SEAN MA: Yeah.
CORI PEELE: Oh, it great.
And I think you mentioned when
you were going through the demo
that you had the ability to
support different types of file
formats.
So if you could talk a
little bit about how you
deal with the compressed files.
So the source file
may be compressed.
SEAN MA: Yeah.
So I mentioned that
Dataprep supports
CSV, JSON, Excel
files, but it also
supports conversions
like GZIP and BZIP.
So as that data
is stored already
on Google Cloud Storage, able
to read that in fairly easily.
CORI PEELE: Oh, excellent.
OK.
And with the Trifacta,
you have and you're
marrying what you have
put in place for Dataprep
with your experience
and those tools,
and that's married to our
Google Cloud infrastructure.
SEAN MA: Right.
CORI PEELE: And so can you talk
a little bit about Trifacta
and maybe expertise or
professional services
when it comes to
getting people set up
and getting started and trained.
SEAN MA: Sure.
Yeah.
So as I mentioned,
Trifacta is just
focused on data preparation
and making sure users
are successful.
So as part of that,
not only do we
have services, options
where we can come in and do
some initial onboarding
and training on how you use
the tool, but we also have
a lot of free resources
in the form of tutorials,
blogs, documentation.
So all that's available, both
in the Dataprep documentation
as was from Trifacta itself.
CORI PEELE: Oh, excellent.
Yeah.
So it sounds like you
have everything available.
So if people want to learn
more about Cloud Dataprep,
they can go directly to
cloud.google.com/dataprep
and learn a lot more.
SEAN MA: Looks like there
was one additional question,
a follow up about the pricing.
So just a question saying,
is the pricing variable?
Yeah.
So just so we're
clear, the pricing
is based on the number of
compute resources that you use.
So while it's a fixed price
for the compute resource,
it varies based on the
number of resources.
So if it's taking more
hours, more compute hours,
to execute a job, therefore
the price will go up.
It's just a price on per
hour type of calculation.
Hopefully that helped.
CORI PEELE: OK.
OK.
Great.
Yes, well stay tuned
for our next session.
Three reasons why you should
run Enterprise workloads on GKE.
And thanks, Sean, for
coming here today.
This has been
really informative.
And I know I'm going to start
doing some additional work
on my Dataprep project
to explore a lot of data
without actually
doing a lot of coding.
So the number of hours
you've saved with that,
I think we all appreciate
that, those us who
have gone through those
sessions in the war
rooms and the meetings.
Great.
SEAN MA: Great.
I was happy to be here,
pleasure to be here.
Thank you.
CORI PEELE: All right, thanks.